hi well welcome to the third and last
session of our mini course there's an
awful lot to go through today and uh but
I did promise it would only be three
sessions long so I'll I'll try to get to
uh not to get bogged down in any one
particular Point um but uh we will
probably continue this on Wednesday in
the in the main class uh uh because you
know if any issues are left over uh on
the other hand uh uh I'll try to get all
the good stuff in today if I can now I
was uh hoping to get through all 27
points on Friday and I only got through
13 so I'm going to start quickly and and
go through the remaining ones point
14 um on our handout sheet was don't use
the same notation for two different
things so um and and and conversely if
you have different things um uh I me
sorry if you have if you have the same
thing you should use the same notation
uh okay so the uh um the idea is in a
bad thing would be to to refer somewhere
to a subj one J and N in one place and a
sub K in another place unless there's
some some good reason um a lot of people
also would would refer a sub I uh an
index is usually called I I think Fier
invented invented index notation using
the letter I but um uh unfortunately I
is also the square root of minus one and
uh this this can is so if you ever come
close to complex numbers uh you you
probably want to get used to using
indexes K and J instead um now um
hello
yes Engineers use J for I because I is
current because I is the is is ampers
yes uhhuh um that's true also so so you
start running out of letters um do
engineers still use J for I my goodness
I I didn't realize the the implications
of moving to the engineering
school what
uh okay now um yeah no I don't I I think
that's dropping out isn't it I well
anyway we I had to I had to do those
labs too okay so it is now here is
saying I'm choosing names for Indy so I
varies from one to M and J from one to n
say in other words if you have different
different ranges um uh it's often um
good good good to stick uh to to
associate M with I and N with j or you
know with K and so on and and to keep
alphabetical order right a lot of times
people will give n first and then M and
somebody says well you know isn't
doesn't M usually come first and uh and
or you have a associated with n and B
associated with M it doesn't seem right
somehow uh it's uh it's there's a little
there's a little Elegance or poetry or
something that goes into choosing
notation um typographic conventions like
lowercase letters for elements of sets
uppercase for sets in in our example
here uh can be quite useful as a as as a
quick guide to to uh to to uh the type
of an object in computer science set now
15 is a is a um it's a really important
one and in the course I'm going to have
an exercise that's based on
removing um unnecessary subscripts and
this text that we have uh writing
mathematics well has an has a a detailed
example of of this and talks about this
at U um it's a it's a common it's a
common F it's a common trap that you can
get into is is um using subscripts and
then you need subs subscripts and so on
and I tried to explain um one of the
most common sources of this trap uh is
if you if you want to introduce a set
and then immediately you you name its
elements with
subscripts uh and so if you start out
and you have a definition and X is
already uh its elements are already
defined as being X1 through xn then then
a subset of X the only way you can do it
is by introducing another level of of
subscripts xub I sub1 through xub I subm
um and and I I saw one one thesis that
was written in France where the where
the guy got into four levels of
subscripts you know he says now consider
a x sub a sub B Sub C Sub sub 1 through
x sub a sub B Sub C all all the
information was in the fourth subscript
um everything else had to just be
repeated over and over again um okay so
uh there's and you'll have to be
speaking of the elements of the set as X
of I and X of J instead of instead of X
and Y or something like this so so the
idea is don't U it's something like late
binding in in computer science don't
don't bind yourself to uh to to to the
need for a subscript unless necessary
and then uh uh you can you know you you
can get into you could even use x sub 1
X sub2 or x and x prime or something as
elements of a of a set okay now the next
is another another uh basic thing uh
important formulas should be displayed
on a line by themselves this uh
um gives them uh gives the reader a
chance to meditate on them at the proper
Leisure and uh to see them um again when
you when you're reading them instead of
sequentially and um then there's
reference numbering convention if you
need to refer to the formulas for remote
parts of the text you give reference
numbers to the and and now here I here I
say that I that um uh that that uh I I
give all of the most important ones even
if they aren't referenced now this is a
little bit uh different from what some
people say but it seems to me that when
that that that there are different there
are sort of two kinds of papers those in
which you you have numbered formulas and
those in which you don't now the ones in
which you have numbered formulas uh
sometimes you can get by with only one
and you can call it star or something
just so you can refer to it as being my
main formula or something but if you
have more if you have several numbered
formulas then the fact that a formula is
numbered um is is uh implicit clue to
the reader that this is that this
formula is fairly is fairly important
and uh so um it it also goes the other
way if a formula isn't numbered the
reader probably thinks well this is just
you know passing interest and not very
important um and so um and so the idea
is then somehow um to keep a a
consistent level you wouldn't number an
equation that was really not not very
important if you if you're only going to
re make a make a uh um a reference to it
that that uh um that's not that's not
terribly exciting the reference can even
be made a little longer the ref can say
the the um the equation in our
derivation of of of some number an
equation or something like that uh in um
uh in order in order not to give too
much prominence to a to an unimportant
equation on the other hand an important
equation even if you don't refer to it
um again some somehow the numbering does
does convey a little Prestige to that
equation so uh uh so so um I I tended in
the art of computer programming to to
number the equations that I that I
thought were were um um high class okay
now seven Yeah Yeah question on ask yeah
uh you when you're writing something
complicated and have to deal with cross
references of any sort equation numbers
are one example uh page and section
numbers elsewhere in a book are another
example uh and things haven't yet
solidified to that point would you
suggest a way of keeping of keeping
track as you go
yeah okay so cross references there's
tables uh T tables figures exercises uh
and so on and uh uh in the final book uh
when it's when it's finally uh Frozen
then these are fixed numbers but while
you're creating the thing they're
they're they're floating and so um like
in the book I'm writing now I've got I I
I assign a tag to every exercise or
table or or formula that I want to refer
to later and um the only problem I have
is remembering what what tag I use to
get the syntax right exactly uh you know
if I misspell it slightly then it
doesn't then then I then it doesn't
match uh so I so I've just been jotting
jotting it down on a piece of paper next
to my terminal um um and then we then
the macros when I when I see a when I
see a draft um the macros will put this
uh put these tags out in the margin
while I'm getting my proof sheets uh so
so that I can see what I call them uh
it's hidden in it's hidden in my
computer file the actual name that I
type for the for the for the tag um and
uh and uh so I I refer to things
symbolically in in my manuscript and
then uh and generate the numbers
consecutively uh uh with the uh uh I
mean the the the macro inside the
computer will will will you know give
the next number uh this this uh least
interesting Paradox is when you're when
you're type setting and you add one more
one more number and something now went
from one digit to two digits and that
means that one paragraph is now one line
longer and that means that one page is
one line longer and everything is is all
screwed up and so you and so then you um
um uh uh you try to fix that because
you've made a page reference uh
somewhere else so the page numbering is
now different so you run it again and
then I think then then uh that flips you
back into the other situation I think
you can get into internet Loops this way
and probably is uh um touring un
undecidable whether or not there exists
a uh a uh a way to break something well
anyway that's another
problem yeah um so the uh uh but anyway
this yeah cross reference is the main
thing is is if you have something hidden
in in a computer manuscript it's a good
idea to print it out on your proof sheet
so you can figure out what what it was
later you don't have to search for it
every time and that's a that that's a a
significant slow down Factor
otherwise uh okay now number 17 is
something again that U that I I notice a
great deal as I'm doing as I'm as I'm uh
re reading and writing is um is this
left to right readability uh as we're as
we're uh as we're speaking to each other
and as we're talking we're our our
brains are are are um anticipating
what's coming up next in the in in in
the sentence um otherwise there would be
no way that U that that we could that we
could communicate with each other or
read books we don't have that great a a
cycle rate inside our heads uh the only
way we could possibly uh do this if you
consider how much information is going
on there is if is if there's some some
way that we're we're Prime to be uh to
be ready for what comes up for for what
comes up we can't be be just responding
and and and keep up with uh with only
with only having two levels of logic
between uh uh per per phon or something
like that so in inside inside our heads
uh we haven't got that much brain power
so so people are are reading um are are
reading these things uh and and as we go
through it helps us anticipate what's
coming ahead and every time are we guess
wrong this uh this slows us down and
makes us uh lose track of of of some of
the main point um so uh a lot of times
I'll put in extra words that that on the
on on uh uh logical grounds aren't
strictly necessary but it but for for
for fast reading are are important for
someone to uh to be able to to see
exactly what the state of the sentence
is as we go along um okay well here's
some funny examples Smith WR remarked in
a paper about the scarcity of data oh
that's the end of the sentence okay so
he remarked about the scarcity of data
and in a theory of rings groups and
other algebraic structures are treated
okay now there are many other there are
many other so I'll often insert another
word to or by or something when I'm
giving a parallel construction I'll say
uh he wants to do this and to do that
instead of he wants to do this and that
sometimes it'll help the depending on on
the uh on the context um and uh so this
left to right readability uh factor is
is something to that that that you
usually catch uh it's something to to uh
to keep in mind as you're doing your
second draft on your first draft you
don't notice this you're writing at a
different in a different rate than when
you're reading when you read something
and when you when you proofread you read
at speed and and there you catch these
things uh that that seemed quite quite
right to you when you were writing them
out slowly
okay uh Point 18 about small numbers now
this is something that I haven't I
haven't seen the rule uh that I think is
right for computer science explained by
the uh by the uh what do you call it the
high Priests of of of of writing in
other books
um they'll they'll they'll tend to use
formulas and they'll say always uh if a
number is less than C some specified
thing depending on your style manual
then it's then then write it out in
words otherwise write it as as digits um
but I
don't uh uh I don't agree with that
certainly I I usually don't write out
the number
13,482 unless I'm writing a check or
something um but uh but
oh well you
know lra uh you know if if you're in
Italy or something it's not
so so
um uh but now they uh and and then these
question is is to when you know the
small numbers is 17 a small enough
number to write out or or should it be
17 but uh but the uh but the point is in
computer science a lot of times we're
referring to numbers Quan numbers
numbers as themselves and and the fact
that it's a number would would we
wouldn't want to write it out and uh and
so I give an example bad the method
requires two passes there you would
defin you should write that out as two
it's the it's the uh it's the English
word two on the other hand I have a lot
of examples here where um
um the uh uh it's it's okay um to to and
in fact correct to use uh um to use
digits and so method two is Illustrated
in figure one oh now here by the way I
have a bug in the file there's too much
space after that period there
unfortunately uh This was done well okay
now if if if if if if you want to use
Tech without uh without paying attention
to U uh to the space after period say
French spacing at the beginning of your
paper and then and then Tech will never
give an extra space at the end Tech
looks for a period and puts a little
extra space at the end of a sentence
um and uh and the typus should should
put a little till a little tie in there
to tie the thing together uh so that it
doesn't happen and it wouldn't break a
line after this after this period either
U but uh okay so sorry that's that's too
far apart okay now it requires 17 passes
I think 17 is a big enough number that
we can that we can write it out oh we
could have said SE VN I think the count
was increased by
two uh that's because two is the is a
number here that was increased by not by
a sort of a uh an English word two but
by by by two the leftmost two in the
sequence was changed to a one okay you
with me on this then so when we're
referring to to to parts of algorithms
that are defin that are that that are
numbers it it would look funny to spell
them out on hand um 19 and a little bit
controversial what you don't like well
I'm curious about uh about quoting two
and one rule between yeah right okay um
a lot of yeah if you um you might have
put quotes around and U all um I've
lately been um uh pleased with the idea
of using single quotes for something
when I'm when I'm coding a piece of text
as a uh as a piece of text as as an as a
textual object and double quotes if I'm
using a quotation of a of a phrase of
somebody else or something like that in
a more traditional usage and uh and so I
could have said a leftmost quote too or
something like that but if you if you
have if you're um writing a paper where
you have a lot of discussion of of of
stuff these quotes get really
distracting and have a lot of them so U
it would be it depends on the context as
to how often you're how often you're
doing this I I'm writing a u um I'm
writing a book where I where I refer to
a lot of um of Hebrew and Greek words
and here I have to U talk about the some
of sometimes the words if I can if I
just put them in italic or something I
don't need a quote around them but
sometime if I'm translating them into
you saying what's the literal equivalent
it means literally then I might put put
a single quote around or something like
that it's a little it gets a uh you have
to develop a style and and play with it
for a while and then then be consistent
and the the varieties of styles are
useful um 19 um I tend to think of of
things like theorem 1 LMA 2 algorithm 3
and Method 4 as proper
names um and capitalize them therefore
as if if somebody this as if they have a
um as if they're a John Smith um
uh this was this was something
introduced by my copy editor it uh in in
um the volume one of the art of computer
programming originally I wrote omal with
lower case and the copy changed
everything to the uppercase except
exercise he left ex exercise 15 was
always left as a lowercase e and I said
why do you do that he said well you
didn't want it to you didn't want it to
seem like such a big deal uh uh you know
one of wanted to think think of it as
sort of an easy thing you know to do an
exercise you know so you don't want you
don't want to dignify the EXC ize too
much but the but the theorems and the L
those were those were some important so
anyway uh that's uh that's a a
suggestion question yeah what about uh
phrases like Oilers theorem or the
deduction theorem yeah the deduction
theorem now Oiler theorem of course I
would capitalize Oiler uh but that's but
but that's another but but uh really
there's uh but words go through a go go
through a transition when they're what
when when somehow they become
lowercased um like uh what okay yeah VAR
say says some people use touring machine
with a lowercase T now certainly so you
know there's there's oian path in a
graph a hamiltonian circuit uh gaussian
noise uh and so on um aelan group where
where these things originally were
capitalized after the names of G are
enable and so on OB and uh but then uh
it's supposed to be the ultimate in in
mathematical Prestige when your name
starts being used with a lowercase
letter um it gets so common nobody even
remembers you know a Tesla coil or
something like this so so
um
uh okay um now the original question
although was something like the the uh
whatever you call it like the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic or
something you know you say capital F
capital T capital a fundamental theem
arithmetic I do I mean uh uh I sort of
you know sort of quaint uh to uh to do
that if it depends if I'm using it an
awful lot or if I sort of uh uh just
think of it as u i if it it somehow
depends on my on the context and I
haven't got a definite uh UND definite
rule sometimes I guess I would I would
do it Oilers theorem I think I would I
wouldn't capitalize the T um unless it
was but ucl's algorithm I might
capitalize the a because it's such a
it's such a uh venerable old
thing
uh okay extract a rule from this yeah
the extract the rule is is that that
that capital letters tend to to to
denote vulnerability uh and and and non
uncommon ality somehow Yeah question
question uh what about acronyms like for
TR and list people continue to spell
those with all capitals yeah that's true
uh the
acronyms are are uh well actually Lis
now I asked McCarthy and he he's he's he
waffles on this he says he thinks he
doesn't really know if it's if it's if
it's a acronym or or not but he would
tend to write it without all caps
himself um Fortran definitely is an
acronym and would and uh uh and uh all
caps doesn't look too good so so use a
kind of a small Caps or something if
you're for you know typographic style or
something like that Pascal is definitely
not an acronym and should not be C
should not be done in all caps uh
pl1 uh is Mis is an example of a
misspelling here on point
21 uh uh and uh it I don't know but goes
with the goes with the with the the
designers of the language metap fond is
all cap so um
me
uh a preposition is a bad word to end a
sentence with now now this these These
are self-contradictory maxims here and
uh and I and somebody pointed out to me
at the top of the previous page I even
used by the fact that here in my and I
didn't even didn't even notice that I
don't even know how to shorten this word
so by the fact that seem you know I told
you not to use by the fact that it's not
it's it's usually redundant but here I
liked it um a prepos I don't see too
much wrong with this sentence but I come
from Milwaukee and people in Milwaukee
talk that way anyway um so uh
uh often then often ending um sentence
with a but usually you can do better
with than ending a sentence with a
preposition um the second one when
dangling watch your participles now this
one um is is kind of funny but it's not
really an example of a dangling
participle um and I was trying to think
of a good example of a dangling
participle and and I and I still haven't
got a good one what you got
one oh yes good on arriving in Chicago
his friends met him at the
station um this uh uh in other words if
if you start out a sentence with uh with
a uh something has an in in it that's a
participial construction like this and
on arriving in Chicago then the subject
of the sentence is supposed to be what
that in refers to so on arriving in
Chicago his friends met him at the
station that meant that his friends
arrived in Chicago it's a little bit uh
okay a soldier of proved Valor they
entrusted him with the defense of the
city City young and inexperienced the
task seemed easy to me see that the
right way to do that young and
inexperienced I thought the task easy on
arriving in Chicago he was met at the
station that sort of thing so that's
dangling participles this is Strunk and
white page
um about them sentence
fragments now now uh this is a this is
run on two counts but uh uh sentence
fragments can actually be extremely
powerful and and and and and and just
the right way to get the point across to
have a to have a fragment of sentence
that doesn't have a subject of predicate
uh but when you're doing it you're
you're supposed to uh it's supposed to
be because the punch comes you can say
uh uh like you can say uh wait a minute
uh that's wait that's that's that's not
a sentence fragment that's do appear you
can
say use sentence fragments never okay
good thanks Tracy and don't forget it
okay that's a that's an imperative so
that's okay but um uh many times you'll
you'll find people your your favorite
writers are are are definitely using
sense fragments beautifully well but um
it's it's uh it it disturbs the normal
Rhythm because normally a sentence
contains a subject and a predicate and
and therefore um when you use it you
you're get you're doing it for an effect
not for not as a not as a standard
thing make each pronoun agree with their
antecedent that one what with his
antecedent
okay don't use commas which aren't
necessary we're going to talk more about
this this rule later and try to never
split infinitives okay now I got a list
here in Rule 21 these are this is based
on many years of experience grading term
papers and I I added to this list uh uh
uh but these are these are things that I
have seen misspelled at least 20 times
on term papers and so they're they're
real uh ones to ones to learn to use
properly so so please read them oh it's
everybody knows this like quick quick
rule why is it when we have possessive
pronouns when you say theirs and its and
his and hers and and ours uh we never
put apostrophe in every every time else
you have possession you put an
apostrophe in but pronouns when they're
possessive they don't have the
apostrophe
okay now there's the questions about
hyphenation um and U and words go
through a a sequence of of uh uh of
getting less and less hyphenated the
more common they become when when a new
word is coined it it it's hyphenated and
then and then later on somebody finally
decides to drop a hyphen um yoyo I think
is no longer necessarily
hyphenated um used to be um and non-
negative nonzero tend to be in that
category nonpositive
maybe um but um uh what is it
non I can't think some non monotonic
non-
monotonic it's it yeah probably not
anyway a lot of these non words are uh
start out being hyphenated and then and
then uh depending on and then usage
eventually gets gets the hyphens removed
this happens in in in ordinary uh words
as well as as mathematical words now
here's here's something that I that I uh
got to say something about Wich versus
that um uh uh I used to always say which
much more often than I should have and
uh some people would comment on the
drafts of my book and they would they
would say Don you should say that in
fact I gave this course and people would
would would uh would would talk talk to
me about about uh which and that and I
didn't understand and and and all of a
sudden um another copy I got another
copy editor and the other copy editor
marked lots of them in volume in the
second edition of volume two and I um
had that on a computer and so I started
going through with a computer search for
every place I used the word which and
and I found uh that there was a simple
algorithm to decide where she had
changed it to that and where it was
which and that is I look at the at the
at the thing that immediately precedes
in the text if it's a comma or
preposition then I change it to
that uh no if it's not a comma or a
preposition I change to that I so so if
it's if it's just followed by something
else then I change it to that um the
there was another case when it's used
interrogatively like I say which uh
which rule is this but um um okay the
main cases are preposition you can say
by which in which and then you can say
comma which that's okay but otherwise um
uh leave it up so here I have don't use
commas which aren't necessary see
there's no comma in there uh so you
change it which to that but if you put a
comma in then it's okay that's don't use
commas which aren't necessary but that's
saying something that's contradictory
but otherwise uh uh it's it would be you
know if you said don't use exclamation
points which aren't necessary then it
would be quite
valid yeah it means two different things
it means two different things yeah now
now now the idea is that a lot of time a
lot of uh people like me didn't know
this this rule but then now have learned
it in fact this rule sort of kept went
sweeping through the literary
establishments during the 70s and all of
a sudden uh you know you would pick up
uh one issue of Time magazine or
something and and it wouldn't be a
single Wicked Witch in the entire in the
entire uh uh issue and and Ever After um
and and and you can you can you pick up
novels and the novel either has all
kinds of of wicked witches in it or or
it has none and um and it not it
disturbs me very much now because I hear
people quoting from my old books and
they'll say you know can said such and
such and it has witch in there I say oh
did I say that and I hate that
um and uh okay so the
um uh uh so so this so it it's uh it's
something that's now very much more more
prevalent in America than in England too
that this uh this idea but you can
certainly notice it in the books and and
I and I find myself uh marking this over
and over again on on uh drafts of thesis
and so on that that I'm reading um and
and so uh it really works a lot better
to use the word that in unless it's it's
preceded by a comma or or
preposition uh now let's see what else
was it here we're talking about
punctuation but here's punctuation
before a
display um a lot of times people put an
extra colon before display and I
wouldn't uh I and I don't like that
that's what the point of that rule is uh
now here's another one the opening
sentence should be your the opening
paragraph should be your best paragraph
its first sentence should be your best
sentence now this this this sets the
theme for the whole thing if you got a
really great beginning paragraph the
reader is hooked anyway and and and he
won't even notice if you do if you're
sloppy the rest of the way through very
much um uh the uh uh but but if if you
if you have a really bad start off the
reader is going to say oh no I'm going
to have to I'm going to have to get a
comfortable chair to read this to read
this document um and uh the worst the
worst possible start um and I've seen it
on many and many of term paper is to say
n x is y and it's just a dead sentence
and it just leaves you leaves you
completely uh um uh what do you call it
um bored at the end of the sentence uh
so An important method for internal
quick sorting is for internal sorting is
quick sort and uh you know so much
better to start out be direct cor quick
sort is an important method for internal
sorting and say why because it's quick
you know okay
um uh a commonly used data structure is
the priority cue you can tell what what
term papers I was quoting from I was
teaching a data structures class once
once um and so U you start out and you
instead of saying X is y you say Y is
something in y explain about it and that
that gets right that's much more lively
okay boy I'm running out of time the U
uh 25 is about
punctuation and here I've got single
quotes as an example of referring to a
word in itself always end your program
with the word end now um
people um there's there's a uh uh an old
long-standing rule that uh commas and
periods tend to go inside of quotation
marks but semicolons and and exclamation
points of things don't and um the reason
is is that it looks better and uh and
that people are used to it and so when
they see something that they're not used
to then they then they uh forget what
they're reading and they start thinking
about the form of the document instead
of the
content um so um now um uh Orin my
co-author has suggested a compromise and
that is that um that um uh we can use we
can use both conventions but but
backspace and and sort of sort of go
halfway uh now he wanted to do it the
other way he wanted to take to put the
quotes and then the period outside but
then back back up a little bit so the
period is a little closer to the quote
uh so that it won't won't stick won't be
quite so noticeable you know but I but
but for me that was still too noticeable
so I so I have the period inside but I
back up the quotes a little bit so that
so that so that we're getting closer to
anyway um we can do but but um um to to
me it's still it's still uh um uh uh
looks looks a little strange to me to
see your period
uh outside of a quote although I think
Phyllis did it here
somewhere uh in the previous parts of
the notes I don't
remember um what it was in it it got in
here somewhere maybe
what oh yeah yeah okay yeah but there's
yeah but here but here I'm really
referring to a word around yeah I'm
really probably a single quote would be
would be would be better there yeah
less instead of fewer
yeah
um okay somebody Martin mentioned since
instead of because the other day oh I
wish you hadn't said that because all of
these rules do restrict you a lot you
know I I've already thrown out four
senses out of that book since since uh
Wednesday um but use parallelism when
parallel concepts are being discussed no
the Comm is inside Mater is outside
where are where are you I'm sorry uh
the Comm outside the
period yeah yeah yeah yeah I would I
think this should be this would
be this would probably be better there
and there's and and the rules are really
strange Mary CLA has a has a nice long
discussion about this where you when
you're giving dialogue uh uh you put the
U the thing in um the uh you know
something John
said uh and he did say the comma but the
comma is always inside the quote he said
it with a
period
um okay uh now but there's something
that anyway that's wishy-washy this idea
of there's there's different uh people
are saying let's go for logical
punctuation now and forget these These
Old formal rules and uh and then we
we'll have a revolution and that and
that and there are people that that are
thinking that way and and pretty soon
it'll happen I suppose um but there's
something that has to be right and that
is uh it has to be logical with respect
to parentheses and brackets and so this
I I see this a lot uh here's an bad
example that that's that does it you
know both things wrong you got to have
uh uh the the parth the punctuation
should make sense without the
parenthetical remark and so I would I
would uh in order to fix this up what do
you do you you move the period outside
the the P and you take out this
comma um jargon now there was a uh oh
yeah long strings of nouns as adjectives
the packet switch data communication
Network protocol problem I uh Terry
wiard had an example of an infinite
sentence that went went on I mean it
potentially got into a loop and and and
would go on and U um uh and this tends
to be a uh a defect of modern
engineering technology and and uh uh it
can get it can definitely be overused um
jargon is there a very interesting
experiment was made by people at the
communication Department here about 15
years ago they took some technical
papers and they rewrote them without
jargon and gave them to people in the
technical field to to read uh who would
who would presumably all know the jargon
and be used to it in their papers and
they also G they also gave this to uh to
a variety of other kinds of readers but
they they they they edited papers simply
to take out the jargon not to change
anything else and in all respects um the
um this was an improvement by rated
rated better by all readers as far as
the the the paper being more easy to
understand they were they they passed
better comprehension tests on it and
everything um even though it was for
Specialists now it's very it's very uh
it's very tempting when you when you uh
uh uh when you when you're writing a
paper in a certain field to show that
you've done your homework and you know
all the buzz or all the things that the
way people are talking about it but uh
in fact uh um you're better off if you
if you don't use this unless uh it's
it's a concept that that's needed so
often in your paper that you needed it
for an
abbreviation um uh now um uh when I
started working on typography I I uh
started learning the that there was all
kind of technical terms for different
parts of letters and and and things like
this and it was very and so when I wrote
an article about these things I I I sort
of uh felt like I I should I should use
all these all these Grand new words that
I didn't know last year uh and I had to
you know realize that this temptation
was was not actually improving the the
clarity of my paper was just trying to
be a little bit of uh one upmanship not
too good uh here's a here here's a great
U uh example quoted out of a book called
mathematics made difficult and uh
there's a book this book is in the
library uh it's a wonderful book to to
uh it's it's full of it's it has the
longest proof of 2 plus 2al 4 that
you've ever seen and U and this is um if
you read through this uh you will see
that it's precisely equivalent to this
another sentence which I was fortunately
able to quote from my own book um uh
which was about the
factorization um and uh so anyway I this
has a a bit less jargon in it although
certainly I still wouldn't use the same
thing when I was talking to a a third
grade
class um U now part 20 Point 27 when in
doubt read my book for outstanding
examples of good style uh this was a
joke and um and humor is something very
important I I think to to mention in in
writing I think it helps to um uh to to
uh uh keep a light attitude to the
subject U making it so that a person
person actually uh there are there are
some authors where we like to read what
they wrote even if we aren't necessarily
interested in the subject even though
it's a technical subject and uh and but
the best use of humor is if if the joke
doesn't get stale or you know it has it
can't be too
corny I mean some of the puns in um in
this book that uh that I'm working on
now uh I I I really had to had to kill
um and um but um but uh uh and and
everybody has different um standards of
humor so there's there's and this this
this changes year by year also but the
but the the goal to keep in mind is that
is that if a person can get the idea
that there that there's a joke there if
he only understood the material then uh
then that's another motive for the for
the reader to to understand the material
and so so such uses of humor tend to be
the most effective is where they where
the person uh says you know I I I think
I'd really enjoy this if I if I if I
gave it a little more thought and then
then they would now the guy who wrote
mathematics made difficult had this
other quote here which I mentioned it
says as empty is absorbing on the left
neutral on the right like British toilet
paper and this I thought was a was a um
was was a was making a good point
um um if you've ever been in Britain now
now I wrote a paper called the toilet
paper problem in uh in in the math
monthly and I was tended to go tended to
go too far and how much the editor uh uh
wisely cautioned me against it I mean it
turns out that there were very many
words have a double meaning and I I and
I had a sub like I had a subtitle called
the process of elimination and and U and
uh and he said no this was just you know
you a year from now Don you aren't going
to be glad that you wrote that
so so he was right yeah I wanted to
think I want to say one more thing the
opening paragraph Was Your Best
paragraph when I I gave this this
homework assignment once before to and I
remember uh Steve vegal um uh solution
to it uh uh he said your opening
sentence should should really catch the
attention and so he started out he said
ripping off her dress he
said you know let L CNP be a subset or
something what gone yeah the Overflow
room won't be one one in erl yeah one in
erl won't won't be an overflow room
after after today that's right yeah okay
uh now let's see can I uh we still have
some minutes I would like to take a look
at a couple of the papers that you did
and uh and see what what what came on
without what boy boy people have been
using tech for these um it's interesting
now okay so let's take a um a random
example
here
okay uh oh this is uh uh okay LMA if l c
and P then and C une equal mty then C
unfortunately the LMA is not true
consider yeah um now okay okay so this
is a now what okay so uh now this now
some mathematicians use this notation to
mean to mean contained in or equal to
and some means some use it to mean
proper subset and if you and if you if
you if it's if it means proper subset
it's not true uh so let's go but um but
anyway here we so let's change to to to
to this notation that was a typ
typographic error in the uh in the
remark okay so let's let's try this now
uh so since m can be zero C and C imply
C uh oh we got to put something between
this between these two uh between these
uh two two two things here right so um
the hypothesis uh
uh uh C in C implies C in L of c and P
that c is a subset of L of c and
P um that's okay it follows from this
and from uh this that c is
contained in a San uh okay um and uh
yeah he's he's doing the logic he's he's
trying to repair it in either in either
direction and uh but I I would assume I
I let's just make this correction less
than our equal over here uh so we will
prove such and such by contradiction
assume not about them sentence fragments
um that's awkward that's
awkward if you know I would say you know
if p is not in if if p is not contained
in a and there is a vector there is a
vector p in P such that P is not in uh
thus so on now okay now there's a
there's a there's a a general uh thing
about how long the sentences should be
and and whether or not to have have a
semicolon ER or stop the sentence and
put a and and and start a new sentence
there and that that that only uh that
depends on the context and on the flow
as you're reading it as to whether I
would put I would I would uh I would
break the sentence there or not as I as
I'm typing something up I often break a
sentence into two parts and I take out
parenthesis often too when I'm writing a
manuscript I'll often have a remark
which I put in parenthesis and I'm
typing it and I and I take out the
parenthesis that's uh doesn't seem to be
very parenthetical after I'm writing it
but after afterwards but before anyway
anyway here it could go it could it
could go on here for some ey less and K
thus b i greater than BK for some I less
than K choose any Vector C and C since
it's it's a subset of a n we know that a
sub I less than or equal a sub K if we
choose n is equal to this number here
and P of J for I would put a comma here
um if I have a sentence starting with a
long Clause I definitely want a comma
for for for for breaking tells you the
next thing starts yeah but I still want
a comma um if if something then then I
this is uh this little extra added
redundancy is uh useful for parsing it
um and besides this was an awfully long
Clause my teacher used to say if it's if
it's four words or more put a comma
after the introductory clause this is
more this this this gra um then the
resulting vector v such and such as in
LC and P and hence in a sub n since m is
this and since and okay again I put a
comma here um this word s is nice
because it it helps it helps parse the
the continuing thing it would you know a
lot of people would leave that out but
it's it it I think it helps and since it
follows that a prime greater than equal
stringing these things together probably
this is mathematically correct
because but this contradicts that V and
N hence are ass Incorrect and P and so
on okay so um that's reasonbly let's go
to another one
um take choosing at random
which one should I do call left or right
next one this one
okay okay here we
go
um now oh uh let's see before I forget
there is a hand on did you get it what
has it been passed on yeah oh okay
where's my
copy oh okay so I have a a handout which
was which was uh sort of my solution to
this written some time ago um and
um and uh before I forget well no let me
go through this first uh okay now we
show that if LC and P is a subset of a
subn then p is a subset of a subn okay
this word now is is uh is reasonable
sometimes to uh to to punctuate the
things or to give the give and uh the
only trouble is you can't use it very
often of you can't use it you know twice
in the same paragraph uh something is
this happens now but after after you've
got the setup you can say now but you
can't say now and then now this and then
now that that gets pretty tiresome but
it's a it's it's it's reasonable uh it's
not necessarily I don't know about the
comma there but it's not too bad we will
prove the result by contradiction
suppose that LP contain an a sub in but
this okay now I like the word that there
as I told you the other day then there
exists the vector
v a
vector R in P such that R is not in a
subn therefore comma there exists now I
wouldn't put the comma there that's
pretty short uh introductory phrase
therefore there exists indices whoops
there exist indices I and
J with I less than J but the plural of
index is indices um and um except if we
talk talking about the indexes of two
different books uh these do do all books
have indexes um and there's vertexes and
vertices I um I uh uh my copy of once
changed vert vertices to vertexes all
the way through and I just couldn't and
I just couldn't do it it was I had never
read a book on graph theory that talked
about vertexes and it just I just
couldn't I had to change them all back
again even and galy proofs um
okay there there exist IND indices I and
J with I less than J such that R sub I
less than R subj he hasn't Define the
notation R sub i and r subj so you got
to so we have to uh have to so this is
undefined notation got to figure out uh
you got to got to say R equals r sub1 r
R2 r subn or something like
that
um okay since this is in Asen then for
any oh that's that's that's awkward
since this is an equal a then for any
Vector a it's uh it better to take a
sentence like this and
completely completely break it into two
parts
um uh so this this this this this sence
here is awkward I don't have a quick fix
for it another now you see we had it had
it twice here too many uh and then the
this the U sentence style seems to be
very much the same uh a lot of times an
introductory word followed by comma it'd
be better to have a little more variety
there um if you could say if we now let
I suppose but um if we let k equals this
which is a non- negative integer because
such and such we don't we we have have
oh that's that's a little bit rant there
we have have C okay c plus c i+ i r is
in a
subn
um all right uh now let's see I I want
to hit the um highight high spots
here uh because there are several
problems but uh I element jth element
that's not too bad to refer to that
usually typograph typographically this
will be in metalics but you don't need
to hyphen in between them some people
put hyphen there but I don't think it's
necessary um but this IE I want to talk
about that
um uh the word iie uh the phrase IE and
EG should almost always be followed by a
comma
um and uh but it's probably better not
to use it at all
unless it's a nice short way to say that
is uh an EG is a short way to say for
example um and and uh some people use EG
for that is and ie for for example but
uh uh you know but uh but generally put
a comma after after them if you if you
do use them I don't didn't I didn't
specify that elsewhere but it's almost
always better cuz this is in apposition
with everything other stuff there
question yeah what about using etc etc
yeah well Etc is um it don't spell it
ECT uh in the first place e um and uh
Etc is
uh is uh tolerable uh although and so on
and and so forth It's often often look a
little a little a little better to the
to the reader um in the in the
handout uh I pointed out at the end uh
another another important aspect of
mathematical Exposition and that is um
the uh the proof by contradiction is is
can often be replaced by by a direct
proof which is which is both easier to
present and uh and and often proves more
and and uh so so although proof by
contradiction is a nice way to if you're
to solve a problem it gives you extra
hypothesis to work from uh often you can
you can uh do better and so I and so I
rewrote the proof without using the
proof by contradiction this is another
point also stressed by Gilman in in the
text um and uh so the so the proof by
contradiction allows you to to get byy
with fewer fewer hypothesis if you look
if you look through it just just to see
a lot of times there's a false proof by
contradiction somebody doesn't use the
the hypothesis really another thing that
uh that isn't necessary is to choose I
and J with B you can always go I I + one
if a vector is in decre non- decreasing
order if it only if the adjacent
components are in in order and so uh
that would that would um make a slight
Improvement to the exposition so the so
although we were to our writing
assignment was to rewrite a specific
Exposition there's another point is that
uh uh there's often also a better proof
in in mind uh try to think about that
when you're writing up a proof uh try to
avoid proof by contradiction unless it's
unless it's really important element of
the proof question yes uh you use the
phrase it follows that yeah uh is that
best used once or twice uh it follows
that now that's another that's one of
the six I don't know what's that it's a
four syllable way to say therefore and
uh um
and it it would be bad to use that
phrase over and over again um but I can
use it uh I can I can probably use it
twice on a page maybe um so there are
some things you can't even use more than
once a chapter but this one isn't isn't
in that category but it's not like you
know a lot of uh the variety
um uh is is it's an issue if if if every
sentence uh if every sentence has this
saying da da then then you then it
quickly gets tiresome and so but but you
just you just switch switch around
between two or three possibilities and
uh and people have forgotten already
that you've used the previous one yeah
okay well thanks a lot uh on Mon on
Wednesday I'll I'll I'll come up with
some other neat Choice examples from
your homework if I can think
of